warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is advised obviously people
who have this condition of gender
confusion have much higher rates of
anxiety of depression suicide what is
gender dysphoria if it ain't mental
disorder
[Applause]
my patience the devious diva you could
ever think us transgender issues are
finally making it mainstream so
naturally we're gonna science this up
and there is no scientific evidence that
any of that decreases after the surgery
this is what I want to do nobody can
change genders and as a number of people
who still practice the surgery have
recently testified there have been
increasing rates of regret in trying to
undo the surgery I was born a male I
started living as a female when I was 19
years old had a sex change when I was
thirty years old I've now been living as
a woman for 28 years and I fully regret
this so not everything is gray and I'm
happy I'm not happy the bad one wish you
know never have taken that first
testosterone shot are we truly
biologically the sex we identify ass
let's talk about that now find out on
this episode of LED live
[Music]
exposing darkness so we are gonna be
talking about gender babylon babylon
just means confusion in the bible right
so there's a lot of gender confusion out
here
and I don't care how like much you think
you know about this this is confusing to
anyone I don't want to be disrespectful
I know this is a sensitive topic but
this is confusion and you'll find out
we're gonna talk realistically about
some of the complications pros and cons
with this what are you guys thinking
right now when you see this yeah I
wonder if like I maintain like cuz he's
wearing a with that corset but that's
not the natural frame of a man that's
true I was gonna say a lot of women will
do a lot to look good you know heels and
all this it's painful but you're right
his frame isn't even made for this so I
want to go ahead and say I many years
ago I used to dress a little like this
you know I wasn't I would never say that
I was transgender I never felt like a
woman trapped in a man's body but I did
have them on set like clothing as
clothing who's gonna tell me that cotton
sewn in this shape is just for women you
know so here I am with pantyhose all
over I'm actually wearing a skirt in
this picture so you know I get it I've
been down that road I'm not just you
know somebody who hasn't no idea what is
going on right now but I do see that we
see Hollywood has a big influence in
this Jaden Smith he's pushing the limits
with this trans clothing which I
probably would have really been into
this watch a little clip here Laverne
Cox definitely my favorite right now
she's she's amazing I love her I think
she should be if there's gonna be a
trans spokesperson I think it should be
Laverne Cox definitely I think Miley
Cyrus very big very big like inspiration
with me especially when it comes to
gender she is just like fighting hard
for the trans community
she is so open and accepting with that
and she's a very big voice and I
appreciate her for that
I love Jaden Smith yeah Jaden Smith is
doing a really good job of freaking like
the clothing gender norm I think it's
really important for celebrities and
people who have a wider platform to
utilize that to make people more aware
of what's out there if you know at least
somebody else is out there even if
you're not like connected with them say
you're just cognizant of Ruby Rose just
existing in the world being their
beautiful self it's just really nice to
know that somebody's out there that
could possibly help you so I kind of
identify with Jaden you know I don't
think he's gay he probably doesn't feel
like a woman but he's just like I'm just
expressing myself through fashion I
don't believe there's a guy or girl
clothing I'm just gonna if I like it I'm
gonna wear it you actually see that a
lot in the hip-hop culture when you see
a lot of hip-hop guys starting to shirts
dresses and stuff like that it's kind of
crazy that was Khalifa and all those
guys so that's the kind of month so that
I can kind of identify with I can't
connect with feeling like I'm a man or a
woman Shep's on a man's body or vice
versa so we do see Hollywood really
pushing for this mindset you see a lot
of Hollywood mothers raising their
children gender neutral or even boys
wearing dresses and stuff so I do
believe there's some kind of push that
Hollywood is putting us out there
because this was not even an issue ten
years ago I mean there's nothing new
Under the Sun
you know the Bible talks about
homosexuality Bible talks about wearing
the opposite clothing for your sex so
it's not new but at the same time we're
seeing like this coming out for this and
I think there's a push
[Music]
I'm a girl could have just as easily
been a boy though because the
probability of becoming a girl is always
1 into C inside each of our cells are
these things called chromosomes and they
control whether we become a boy or a
girl
your mom has two X chromosomes in all of
her cells and your dad has one X and one
Y chromosome in each of his cells before
you're born your mom gives you one of
her chromosomes and your dad gives you
one of his mom always gives you an X and
if dad gives you an x 2 then you become
a girl but if he gives you his Y then
you become a boy see there are only two
possibilities a girl X Y the chance of
becoming either a boy or a girl is
always 1 & 2 a 50/50 chance either way
it's like flipping a coin X your girl Y
your boy some people are just lucky I
guess so
this is an old Bill Nye yeah yeah I was
just gonna ask in the 90s because if it
was released this year probably
completely different oh yeah very very
interesting because this is actually on
Netflix some of the old ones and this
scene was cut out this one little
segment of that of this episode was just
missing so how did you find this scene
because somebody must had a VHS or
something but I think when they first
put on Netflix it was on there and then
I saw a video where somebody was showing
look it's missing now yeah because
fended by science like what yeah but he
clearly has a different stance now yeah
we'll take a look at what Bill Nye says
now so this says there's two genders
and it's like flipping a coin you're
thinking to be male you're either gonna
be female
I like how they also only say there's a
leak - if there's a leak - dad right
right
right here's something different now
like there's like 63 genders now one
thing's clear about sexuality there's a
lot more going on than meets the eye
[Music]
female or male gay or straight pink or
blue we were taught to see these as
binary now we're realizing it's more
like a kaleidoscope and this stuff isn't
just for adults parents know this
already kids explore gender expression
attraction before they've ever heard of
a spectrum take sex we used to think it
was pretty straightforward X and a Y
chromosome for males two x's for females
but we see more combinations than that
in real life and even for people with
just two sex chromosomes hormones can
vary wildly so can Anatomy what makes
someone male or female this is so
clear-cut hmm so what he's saying is we
used to believe that there was only two
we used to believe it was clear cut but
now we're seeing and it's not just an
adult's but it's also in kids why is it
something that we're now seeing what
what was going on a hundred years ago
it's interesting the visual that they're
showing you - is now you can have three
X's and a y I mean is that even like
scientifically possible isn't it only -
I don't know I don't know I think that's
probably what he's alluding to I don't
remember anything like that yeah when I
took genetics but I could have missed
that along the way or maybe they just
weren't talking because it was it's been
a while since I went to school but well
the science hasn't changed this is true
that you know there's two genders you're
either male you're female and it depends
on it whether you have two x's or an x
and a y that is true but he's trying to
throw this like pseudoscience in here
and make it look confusing basically but
we know that this is a mental issue this
is not physical you can't look under
microscope and tell you are trans it is
mental so
that might be something that somebody
would be offended by if you say you know
you have a mental issue but there's a
lot of mental issues you know people
especially if you've had some traumatic
event happen in your life you grew up
without a father you were abused
sexually abused that stuff messes with
you and there is help for that situation
and you know you can recover but we are
being told now that it is wrong to help
people recover that if a kid five years
old a boy says I feel like a girl it is
wrong to say well no you're really a boy
you actually have to embrace that idea
and and and continue forward with it so
what do you think that is Wow I mean
obviously not possible right well look
again yeah it's possible if you're
worried oh just a visit me that's true
is that a woman yes is a biological born
woman but she's been taking testosterone
to get the facial hair and the muscles
and all this yeah that's crazy
well genetically it's the only way that
can work yeah I mean they're just
they're just is no other way
I think what's it seems like what's
being preyed upon and we should be
sensitive of the fact that there are
people who are born with multiple or
varying genitalia you know and and for
that person maybe that could be
confusing you know what you know I
obviously have both parts what what Emma
you know
but you're taking I'm going somewhere
that it's you're taking something that's
out of the norm you know and and trying
to apply that to mainstream whereas most
people you know they're just they're
born the way they are and when you open
that up for interpretation I mean it
really opens up a much a much bigger
question because if you feel like you
are something well what if I feel like
I'm you know whatever what if I feel
like I'm a dolphin or what if I feel
like I'm rich or what if I feel like I'm
you know the king of the world I mean
where do you draw the line I guess I
think if you're biologically one way but
you feel like another way I still don't
think that biologically changes your
biology no I'm not saying that does so
so you know just an even in a topic of
like skin color if I felt like I was not
the skin color that I am would that
change anything no people would probably
look at you and be like no you're crazy
because I can see that but in this one
area I think that it's it's really
gotten that's actually much more
controversial I've seen I wish I would
have the article but there is a woman
who felt like she was black and she died
her skin and her hair and everything and
it was a huge controversial topic so why
is that so much more controversial
that's the thing where do you draw the
line you know you can say I feel like a
man or a woman or even an animal or an
infant but you can't feel like you're a
different race I mean like who's the one
that says no you can't do it this way
you have to do it this way you know so
the definition of gender is medical
definition is sex that's the first one
the number two is the behavioral
cultural or psychological traits
typically associated with one sex so but
by that definition though if you're
psychologically have traits of being one
Jen
even though you're born with a
particular gender I mean I guess what I
would like to see is is this a
long-standing definition where is this a
new definition because if you look in a
dictionary a hundred years ago maybe
even 50 years ago maybe 20 years ago it
probably I'm guessing says something a
little different because I look at that
and I say well you know if you behave a
certain way are you a certain gender if
you culturally are a certain way you're
a certain gender if you psychologically
have more traits in common with one
gender over another then you're
associated with that gender to me I see
that definition is fitting what we
actually see today yeah when I was first
introduced to this topic as a little
girl there it was told to me that there
is a difference there's a separation
between sex and gender two different
things so your sex is your biology
whereas your gender is more of what you
identify with how'd you like that just
in conversation and also in like things
like YouTube and media and things like
that and just being curious about and
hearing someone's perspective it was
just common for there just to be a
separation between gender and sex that's
what you hear a lot of people are the
one thing they always say is there's a
difference between sex and gender but
then there's a lot of times not even a
definition given I just say there's a
difference and you're kind of like well
what is it I guess another thing I maybe
I'm jumping the gun here but as you
think about it there are people that are
not identifying with either gender
anymore so how does that change the
definition of gender because there is no
one or the other it's it's more fluid
yes it's more open to interpretation you
know you say I'm not male or female I
think it's called binary yeah so that'd
be interesting to see how this
definition change
I wonder how another not a nary person
if you would interact with them would
you see they had more feminine or
masculine traits or do they really just
blend that well now there are 63 genders
currently this list was too big to get
in a screenshot it goes all the way down
to here and there's all these different
attributes so we got masculine
homosexual man wait Mikey do you know
what you are do you know like I am a
masculine heterosexual man yes in terms
of gender as a gender or sex now see
this is confusing by it because they
would call you a cisgendered man meaning
you are biologically a man and you own
your masculinity Sears it samus this is
the same it's a woman or female so no
longer am I just a woman or you're just
a man it's this very specific cisgender
then you have you know trans and the
list goes on and on yeah and do you
think that honestly this is finished I
mean are we done I think the more time
goes on there's gonna be alien and
everything else you know because we're
seeing that and I really wish I could
see all of them because I just I I can't
even wrap my head around this yeah what
happens when you start adding like
technology into this situation if
they're you know blending I don't know
machine and man together they're kind of
trying to what what happens to this list
I mean are you uh are you an apple
masculine man or a PC you know yeah
there's I was looking at some statistics
recently and they were pulling people to
see their stance on relationship with
robots you know I'm like that's kind of
an odd thing to pull people on you know
in unless there's some intentionality
there like why would you even pull
people that you know I think I think
where things are headed is way darker
than what we see on the surface I think
it's small steps that are leading us
there Satan wants to have a world of
confusion he loves this and I mean in
the Bible it talks about that they were
creating new ways to sin and we can't
just can't even
what the days of no were like but I
think we're quickly approaching that so
clearly there's a physical difference in
the male and the female what what
physical differences you see well the
man has a lot more muscles or is more
muscular at least in most cases
shoulders are broader typically so hip
structure is usually different so which
one's stronger the male man yeah
the man is strong I mean I think God
made male and female for this like
perfect unity you got the nurturing
woman who can produce milk for her
children who can give birth to a child
and is there you know is the one that
nurtures oh you hurt yourself but the
man he's got to go out there and and do
the work build the house carry the
lumber plow the field and the two of
them together it's perfect unity you can
create life you can sustain life but
what happens when you start mixing you
double this you can't be lacking
something if that was the only choice
you would life would cease to exist
beyond that that's true I mean you you
you have to have one of the both to
continue life yeah I guess bio
biologically I mean there are ways to
conceive you know outside of but that's
a sexual Union however I would add to
that if if that is your preference and
that's what you believe then I don't see
any way that you could actually be like
an evolutionist very true unless you
believe that you know eventually nature
finds away as said in Jurassic Park but
you know if one celled organism split it
somehow did it so if we're to believe in
evolution then
maybe if we keep going down this road
and we're separating the genders and the
sexes maybe we'll become asexual somehow
but where where evolution fails is dead
life cannot reproduce I mean we're all
gonna die before we evolve into some
kind of a sexual being I believe we're
kind of like leaving the postmodern
mindset into the post truth mindset
let's just look at post modernism for a
second so what does post-modernism
post-modernism is the idea that reality
is not mirrored in human understanding
but rather constructed as individuals
find their own reality was true for you
isn't necessarily true for me
it takes a micro rather than a macro
approach and looking at the way
individuals identify themselves compared
to the structuralism view in which an
entire society has looked at post
modernist believe that realities are
subject to change and that apparent
realities are actually social constructs
which limit individuals so we we see
problems with this I mean it's if if
there's no set rule then who's to say
pedophilia is wrong or murder is wrong
what's what's true for you is not true
for me Hitler was he had a good idea in
his mind he wanted to evolve humanity
into perfect beings blond-haired
blue-eyed the the best race and he
looked at other races and he said
they're not human exterminate him he was
trying to evolve humanity in his mind he
was doing something good but I don't
believe that that is a good thing I I
believe in set laws
biblically God gave us a set law that we
should follow and I believe those laws
so we're in this post truth era
relating to or denoting circumstances in
which objective facts are less
influential in shaping public opinion
than appeals to emotion and personal
belief now it can understand how you
know we have to conform to this oh you
feel like you are not the gender you
were born as I have to cater to that I
have to call a boy a girl I have to you
know we have to cater to this because
your emotion Trump's physical reality
and truth and what's ironic is that I
mean so many atheist who say I'm an
atheist because I believe in science I
don't believe in your fairy tale I
believe in you know physical proof I
believe in science yet they're probably
in the post truth mindset where they
agree with well if you feel like a dog
then you can be a dog that totally does
not coexist with I believe besides
what's true and I feel like the world
around me is viewed through the
Christian mindset you know there is a
male and a female and that's how I feel
does that make it truthful based on this
you know I mean so how could you refute
me because that's how I feel if if I'm
saying that my emotional belief system
tells me the world is like this I guess
I would I would even ask the question
that Pilate asked and that is what is
truth I mean the way this is constructed
your Reedus your deconstructing the word
truth even truth now becomes opinion
because in order for truth to be truth
it's something that's set up as absolute
that everybody agrees upon you can't
call it truth anymore because everybody
is going against it you have to call it
now opinion and so we're what we're
talking about is is like moral absolutes
and where does morality come from you
know unless morality transcends you and
I
then whatever you want goes and so
that's that's kind of a foundation to
all of this so you brought up an
interesting point because I was thinking
yeah you know how come
Christians are persecuted in such ways
like well you're not allowed to have
that viewpoint because you you know
you're not allowed to teach that
homosexuality is wrong you're not
allowed to tell people they're wrong why
you you have a feeling that that is
right so how can they tell you that
that's wrong but at the same time if you
go with that then you have to say well
then I must accept that this man is a
dog this is where it gets really
confusing because it's like you you want
to justify one way but then in order to
do that you have to take this other way
too or do you so that's like where the
discussion should really go because it's
like that's why it's called gender
Babylon it's just pure confusion and how
do we how do we coexist with these two
ideas but there are people whose sex and
gender are not the same as a first
hypothesis scientists thought there
might be a male brain shown here and a
female brain but uh so perhaps a person
could have a male brain and a female
body and a female brain in a male body
or the other way around but there are
people who identify as both genders or
neither gender or a combination of the
two and it turns out you can't identify
the gender of a brain just by looking at
it
gender is like sex it's on a spectrum
so following along along the sign of
thinking if this is a mental issue we
look at people who are depressed and
they want to kill themselves and we
don't say if that's how you feel just go
for it you know we want to help them
when you find people who are anorexic
and you can tell you look healthy you
know not look skinny yet they keep
starving themselves and they look like a
skeleton what if that person went to a
liposuction clinic and said doc I need
liposuction and they look like a
skeleton would it be right for that
doctor to perform a surgery on this
person because of their mental view of
who they are this is where we can see a
parallel because people are saying well
I might look like a man but I feel like
a woman so doctor give me the right
stuff is that really a good thing to do
people you know people say that you know
there's a lot of suicide in the trans
world because they can't transform to
who they want but I have actually heard
cases where people go through the whole
transformation have a different mindset
later in life and they're you more
depressed and commit suicide afterwards
because what have I done to myself
I've mutilated my body
[Music]
so the Lord God and caused the man to
fall into a deep sleep and while he was
sleeping he took one of the man's ribs
and then closed up the place with flesh
I was born a male I started living as a
female when I was 19 years old had a sex
change when I was 30 years old I've now
been living as a woman for 28 years and
I fully regret this nobody can change
genders it's impossible it's delusional
it's a mental illness then the Lord God
made a woman from the rib he had taken
out of the man and he brought her to the
man once I finally had the surgery I
went out this was the wrong thing to do
it was the wrong thing to do to cut off
my male and not I mean
the man said this is now bone of my
bones and flesh of my flesh she shall be
called woman for she was taken out of
man that is why a man leaves his father
and mother and is united to his wife and
they become one flesh the fact of the
matter is the 40% of people who are
attempting suicide are people who regret
ever changing genders
growing up I had a totally different
mindset you saw the picture that I
thought that was gonna be me for life I
was like this is me but you know there's
no gender and clothing I wear makeup and
this is me it's not me anymore that was
a different mindset yet now they're
telling you that parents cannot tell a
13 year old that cannot tell them that
you're not trans it's called child abuse
if a parent interferes with what that
kid feels like when I was 13 I wanted to
get horn implants someone to get my
teeth sharpened I wanted all kinds of
tattoos that I would never get now it
really it really goes to a broader
question you know if you can't tell the
child certain things because this child
abuse where do you draw that line you
know we don't tell kids to go into the
street because you know eventually one
day a car might be coming along and it
could hit them and hurt them so and I
realized that's you know an extreme
example but where do you draw the line
on you know telling them for example
what to eat
well I'm sorry you shouldn't eat cocoa
puffs for breakfast because it's not
really good for you not good for your
health not good for your teeth
but in telling them no and denying them
are we you know
are we playing into that same mindset is
it child abuse that I wouldn't agree
yeah cuz that kid is saying I feel like
eating cake yeah I feel like this is
oatmeal today yeah where do you draw the
line I feel like loving parents are
looking at they have the best interest
for their child and some parents might
even feel like you know when you reach
18 you can make that decision and I'll
support you but right now think about
this you're young things are going to
change I don't think that's child abuse
no the Bible says that we should train
our children you know train up a child
in the way they should go and so if we
are to train them and then society or
the government or whoever says no you
shouldn't train them that's that's child
abuse well you know who ultimately who
do we serve God or man
a great question amen so how do you feel
about this scenario the bathroom bill
says that you know now transgender men
can go into the woman's room and you
might look at it and be like I'm kind of
worried about my daughter my wife like
what if this man followed in behind your
your wife or your daughter would that
concern you or do you think well since
he looks like a woman you should use the
lemons or I still think an easy fix for
this is they don't want a separate
bathroom for transgendered individuals
because they feel that that's coming all
the way back around full circle to
segregation and whatnot right but myself
as as a a straight heterosexual male and
I want to use a bathroom with other
males than the other sex give me a
special bathroom
oh is that special I say we just go to
porta potties everyone there's a
transgender bathroom if you want to
segregate I will raise my hand you can
segregate me and I my oh hey amen
so I think usually the consensus is like
people say I don't want a man going to
the women's room I feel unsafe how do
you feel kandi if this came in right
behind you in the bathroom in the car
I'm just gonna be honest it's confusing
to me I don't want to say the wrong
pronoun so we're supposed to say this
that day right I think I would feel
uncomfortable but I'm just the type of
person that also takes the other
person's feelings into consideration
this is just me talking you know for my
from my perspective so you know I would
just look at the situation if there if
there are stalls if you know the person
is like respectful and all that kind of
stuff then then fine but I know that's
not the case for everyone I don't even
know if that answered your question I
come back I don't I don't know basically
you just would clam up and just say just
do what you guys pretty much I mean
basically you're saying you you're
probably not gonna confront the
situation I think there's a lot of
people like that a lot
people probably feel uncomfortable but
they're not confrontational I'm like
that here mad in this there just seems
to be this people are making this
correlation between wanting segregation
with transgender versus male and female
and segregation between races I find
that very interesting
I think segregation in certain
situations are necessary and in other
cases they are are despicable
so you have against segregation with
races definitely no because we're all
people but then you have segregation
between man and woman which is a
necessity it's something that is neat
it's not wrong and when you're talking
about segregation between people who are
biologically man biologically woman then
you have this other would it be wrong to
celibate those people I don't see why
that would be because in a sense no
matter how you try you cannot relate if
a man wants to become a woman let's just
say okay fine we accept you you are who
you are but still you cannot relate to a
biological woman a woman who has natural
things that go on in her body that you
will never experience a woman who goes
through society with just things that
they will never experience and vice
versa I have no idea what it's like or
what's going through a mind of a
biological woman who identifies as a man
and I don't expect to ever relate to
that so why wouldn't they want that
segregation of that safe space for
themselves and why am I not validated
and saying that I want a safe space for
women who go through what I can relate
to and if I talk about something it's
not something that's unrelated to the
next person I agree with that completely
I do and I think when I start making
these comparisons with race segregation
it's just a way to emotionally
manipulate the person into
one has nothing to do with the other
exactly so so here's where it gets
confusing and and this is where all of
this is confusing because I actually
have sympathy for the people the
lawmakers who are having to deal with
this because this is the other scenario
so if this bathroom policy is already in
place in so many areas in the United
States then why are people so terrified
I know this is Chase transy oh he's a
lawyer at the ACLU and he's transgender
you do yeah I know why why tell me why
well I think people are really anxious
about the fact that we have to share
public space with people who are
different from ourselves in general and
right now there's all this attention on
transgender people so people are
focusing all of the fear and confusion
about who trans people are around their
anxiety about the bathrooms in general
and trying to expel transgender people
from public space we've seen it over and
over again throughout history the
reality is that bathrooms have long been
a battleground and we saw this in the
context of the civil rights movement and
efforts to expel black people from
spaces that white people dominated
including bathrooms and locker rooms
wait what are you doing in the women's
bathroom if I was in North Carolina I
would have to use the women's bathroom
because I was assigned female at birth
so I would be a dude in the women's
bathroom that's with a lot of require
you see that these lawmakers are
literally causing the problem that they
say that they want to avoid in the first
place yeah that's what I'm saying but
can you give me a minute oh yeah sorry
sorry okay so you see how can fusing it
can be how can they even make a set law
because if they say well you have to use
the bathroom of whatever you were
assigned at birth well now you got what
looks like a man in the women's room but
if you do the other way around now you
got well a guy in a dress in the women's
room so I mean I totally agree with you
and not wanting to be a lawmaker it's
like what do you accommodate and what do
you not if you look at people with
disabilities bathrooms a come
not talking about different sexes and
things like that just looking at the
problem which is the disability versus
someone who's a schizophrenic they have
certain things that they need to do when
they're accommodated in certain
situations and definitely not
accommodating others like they actually
are put away and all these different
things when you're looking at gender
dysphoria as a mental illness you know
where's the line in accommodation
because if they're talking about public
spaces well you know is a bathroom a
public space or is it more of a private
space amongst the same agenda because we
wouldn't kick some a transgender out of
a library or or whatever like a
supermarket but then you would in a
bathroom like I don't know it's just
really difficult where do you draw the
line in accommodation versus not
accommodating I have a solution these
people who want to be especially using
their own bathroom I I have no problem
with that I don't even know why this is
really a massive discussion I don't
think that I don't think they even want
us but that's the whole point they don't
want a special bathroom they want to go
to the bathroom they want to go I guess
you know for me the way I look at it a
very practical way you know I think the
people that are probably my guess most
concerned about this are going to be
either people with small children or
women who feel like they're vulnerable
guys generally aren't gonna have as much
of a problem just just guessing because
you know they feel like hey I can take
care of myself if there any kind of
situation to it were to arise generally
you know I can navigate the situation so
I'm thankful that there are like family
bathrooms I have small children and you
know it's very accommodating and and
useful because as a parent sometimes you
have to do you need some extra space you
know then they then
give you in a normal bathroom and
sometimes you have a diaper bag and
multiple children and you know it's hard
to keep track of kids in like one stall
and things like that so I think that's
accommodating I think that's nice and I
think we should continue to have those
kind of bathrooms and if it's really a
problem you know you want your own
bathroom you can go in the family
restroom you know I mean but yeah I
think that solves everything actually
having a family and I've been in lots of
bathrooms like that which is great it's
usually a single stall bathroom and it
solves whatever issue so you know if
there's a concern you have an ability to
go all by yourself no exactly I feel
like the only fix that's gonna be a real
fix is to just make all bathrooms just
open to whoever it is trough tande just
I mean I really just feel like bathrooms
are just gonna have to say bathroom yeah
I think the only real solution is just
you know single stall bathrooms because
there are many situations you'll go into
a bathroom and even though it's a public
space
you're still requiring privacy yeah you
know so they're really the only way to
ensure privacy is you know you have a
single stall it has a door you can lock
it anybody can go into it but it's only
one person at a time here's something
that's always baffled my mind how come
bathroom stalls are like gapped from
here there's just like all this open
area they should just love it like
really like a phone base and nobody what
do you have to worry cuz you wouldn't
see me by I've always felt vulnerable
there's like huge cracks and all the
doors really when you see bathrooms I
mean they're their own Wald's things
when you close it it's it's only you in
there so that would be a good fix it's
moving on
so here's things not to say to
transgenders now I think that it's just
confusing I mean like when you see
somebody how do you know whether to say
he she or they are you gonna offend
somebody by saying by calling them day I
mean I I feel like that's offensive but
here's
are you a boy or a girl is it he or she
or they or what
that's so in right now to be like
hashtag gender-fluid
where do you shop in the men's Illumina
section are unisex die the only
confusion really is if you want to be
referred to a certain way but your
exterior makes it mysterious that's
that's the only really scenario where
it's where it's gay because if I see a
girl I'm going to call her ma'am and
that used to be something that was you
know manners that was good manners that
call yes ma'am yes sir like that's what
parents taught and it was a sign of
respect but now you can literally be
fined by law you can get in trouble for
calling somebody their own pronoun
here's a prime example okay I need your
corporate number because I'm gonna talk
call them and talk about house
misgendered several times in his store I
need your corporate number now get for
me now well I'm gonna ask you for the
fifth time to stop calling me a man
because clearly I'm not gonna pair me
now
which I plan on telling the entire so
this person said it's ma'am clearly but
a woman said sir could you stop cussing
because she it wasn't clear to her and I
saw a lot of aggression delusion and
denial it's not clear clearly you're a
man and not a woman also you wouldn't be
making certain changes you wouldn't be
you know wearing a handbag or whatever
else it kind of looked like that person
had breasts or something like that like
if it was so clear that you're a woman
you wouldn't have to be making all these
changes to look more like a woman so it
may not be as clear as you think it is
and getting so aggressive at someone you
realize how calm the kashrut just the
person working at the crest register was
I'm just trying to defuse a situation
there's so much anger and aggression
coming from this person it's really sad
to watch I think initially my first
impression just you know beef when the
video started playing is I thought it
was a woman from the back you know I
would have but that's the back you know
and when the turnaround happen you know
I yeah and what if you would have just
been like excuse me ma'am and he turns
around and then you're like I mean then
you might feel like well did I say the
wrong thing they hate my he would have
took it as a couple of these I think
there needs to be some some freedom if
you correct somebody you should correct
them I think that you know hey if
somebody wants to be called whatever
they want to be called and they're
they're asking for that respect you know
what does it really matter to you if the
person's like no I'm sorry I'm not a man
I'm a woman okay
sorry ma'am you know and and then go on
with it but to destroy the poor store
and you know to cause such a scene and
like that's okay
but yet the other person just simply
called you the wrong pronoun I see a big
problem with that I think a little bit
of grace like you're saying would be
very helpful and I think people largely
will be accommodating they may not agree
with you there's a lot of things in this
world you know that we as individuals
don't see eye-to-eye on but if we allow
people grace and and and we can be
accommodating in certain situations and
um you know we'll help defuse a lot of
that a lot of that anger as Christians
you know we're not just seeking to
offend somebody any and all time
so it's interesting you say that I was
actually a big big thing for me to view
back at home there was a debate going on
in my church whether we should respect
someone who's going through the
transgender process and call them by the
pronoun that they want to be called by
or by their biological pronoun if you
meet someone and you know biologically
they're a man so you say sir and they
said no I'm a woman some people would
refuse to accommodate that personality
what would you what would you do in that
situation oh I would call them what they
want to be called or just stick to their
name you know yeah I think if it if
they're only gonna be angry about it
there's no point in fostering that anger
and someone right yeah that witnessing
opportunity has destroyed them yeah yeah
I would I would use the name so here's a
situation where you know we saw the the
bathroom situation but now we have a
trans girl or a trans girl who wants to
be in the boys locker room you the
transgender student at the center of a
controversy over changing in the boys
locker room is telling his story now 210
news
Rihanna Creighton is live at a Rancho
Bernardo High School rally he says he's
surprised by all the reaction right see
he expected some complaints he knew that
when he entered the boys locker room
here at his high school that someone
would say something but what he didn't
expect to hear was so much support
there's a community here we have like a
huge 14 year old freshman yawns Briscoe
says he never wanted the attention I'm
not trying to make a statement I just
want to be a boy and change and do the
things that other boys do born a girl
again says he's known since the second
grade he was a boy and only this year
made the decision to use the locker room
associated with the gender he identified
with a scary experience just coming out
to somebody like this so now we're in
the situation where we have a student
who has every right to use the boys
locker room even though the student has
female anatomy controversy erupting
after this parent complained about the
encounter her son had with yen's in the
boys locker room
hundreds showing up taking the issue
before the Poway Unified School Board
meeting Tuesday night I feel like a
spokesperson for Poway Unified told
10:00 news the school is following
California law which says that
individuals must be able to use the
facility consistent with the gender he
or she identifies with some parents are
asking for separate bathrooms and locker
rooms for students like kids who are
transitioning it's not a good way to
solve a problem that the problem that
she's bringing up anyways and that
separation does not mean equal meantime
he says the reaction he's getting from
others is overwhelmingly positive and
it's just astounding to see all these
people who are on my side
now the effort to challenge the law that
allows transgender students to change in
the facilities that they choose failed
to get enough signatures to make it on
to the ballot meantime School District
here tells us that they are listening to
parents concerns and that they would
consider a private changing facility for
all students to use but only if they
want to well I've a Rancho Bernardo high
school tonight real Creighton
10news C I mean they they came up with a
solution just like that as well if they
if there's really a big concern rather
than out steam those individuals to
offer something else that it's like hey
if you don't feel comfortable doing this
you can use that I mean so they figured
out this scenario but what about say the
coach who has to look over the locker
room in this scenario a male coach in
Florida school punishes male teacher for
refusing to watch a naked girl in the
boys locker room I mean this is a man
who his job is to be a coach that's what
he wants to do he's a male coach because
he's a man and now all of a sudden he's
got an individual with female anatomy
and he's being forced by his job to
supervise this scenario it's just like a
question I popped in my head
you know I'd like to see the statistics
the facts you know how many transgender
people are there in the vs. how many
just outright perverts
well that happened what we're opening up
the door to for people to take advantage
of this something new on all angles if
you have even a bathroom that anyone can
use so you're not out in come on
ok well that includes the person who was
just an outright program we would go in
and say I know that both men and women
are in there and it's no problem so I'll
just go ahead and start looking at paper
or whatever the case and I've heard this
debated you know oh why
it sounds kind of extreme but whether
it's extremely knotted something to
consider
I'm going and talking about people's
lives I would agree I think there's
probably way more perverted people that
would try to get into that situation
there is actually transgender I mean I
think that transgenders I don't know
what the exact numbers are but it's not
a very large population so I would be
more there than that in this situation
you're not talking about a pervert
you're talking about a guy who as a job
as a coach being forced to supervise a
young female and I think it's really
cool that this coach what did not just
comply with it he was actually saying no
I don't need to be in the locker room I
would view this and so I'm gonna remove
myself a situation he probably wasn't
wanting to make a big deal about it but
then the school is now making a big deal
about it about him being there I don't
know that's just that's kind of crazy
it's any other clip you know really
saved it
young person who is dusted I felt like
they were being forced into a moral
issue
and you know here I see the same thing
so they're really you know are you
forcing both sides into what they
believe is a moral issue now you have to
come to terms with what is a moral issue
you know and you know to force a man to
watch a person who has female anatomy
under other circumstances you know if
it's a minor you would get in huge
trouble for that you know or it would
even be considered child pornography
so really blurring a lot of lines meant
I said and I need to have much better
definitions to deal with these kind of
situations now we see the 234 House
Democrats two Republicans co-sponsor
bill forcing schools to let male
athletes compete on girls sports teams
that's why I showed the comparison of
the male body and the female body
because now I mean let's face it guys
are gonna be better at sports than girls
I mean if you're an athlete and you take
steroids you get kicked off the team but
you're talking about bringing somebody
on the female team that has all this
testosterone or I mean here's like
what's going on this man identifies as a
woman and he wins first place and the
third place winner
third place calls the whole thing not
fair I mean six foot six 220 pounds
that's not the body of a woman what's a
way that's just like basketball is that
the coach is that no way that's the
player well you know this one is a game
changer Delta college women facing a six
foot eight opponent and in her case
change is a big part of her game
it's a breakthrough on the basketball
court had you been ready for the barrage
of media that you've been getting no I
wasn't it's it's kind of unexpected 51
year old Gabrielle Ludwig is a woman
grew up until July this year was a man
she joined the mission college
basketball team the first week of
December I think that people who are
either LGBT they should be able to be
themselves even though there's there
might be a million people telling them
no don't don't do it you know follow
your heart at six-foot-seven the move
was embraced by her own teammates it was
yes easy we didn't really have to think
about it we didn't think about her being
a transsexual she's six seven who
doesn't want that
this team has an advantage female
athletes crushed by women who were once
men transgender MMA fighter the muscle
mass is gonna be way much way bigger
than the female so here's it now to a
GMA exclusive to transgender high school
runners but they're kicking up Dustin
Connecticut taking the top spots at the
state girls championship leaving parents
wondering if they have an unfair
advantage Lindsey Davis is here and you
sat down with the track star to talk all
about this that's right Michael we're
talking about a subject that's so
sensitive that Andrea and Terry who
you're about to meet felt what it was
time to tell their parents that they're
transgender they each revealed it by
text and now they have gone public with
it and they're facing opposition from
people who say even though you may feel
like a girl you need to compete against
the boys Terry Miller and Andre Yearwood
dominating the competition at the girls
track and field championships in
Connecticut earlier this month
coming in first and second place
respectively so this these two
transgenders dominated first and second
place so it sounds like they have an
advantage so what if you said well all
all people in sports must play against
what they were born with well then
here's the flipside you got sorry but
before you move on yeah listen to the
language that the two transgendered
persons dominate the sport well yeah
obviously and it's only those two and
they're destroying all the other person
second place there was a biological
woman and no one sees a problem with
this they do but they don't know to do
with it that's where the confusion is
because if you say okay well we got to
make a rule against this now you have to
play against people with with you're
born assigned gender here's a scenario
this is a she was born a female she's
transitioning but she is if he has been
if he has been taking hormones or
steroids he should be wrestling boys
this girl this transgender girl is
wrestling on the female team but she's
been taking steroids in any other
situation this would be against the
rules you'd be kicked off the team but
you can't say anything because it would
be a hate crime to say you can't take
steroids when you're transitioning it's
child abuse to say you can't do this
this is where it gets messy because they
would still be unfair for this trans man
to wrestle against girls because he has
a at an advantage but for vice-versa I
believe for the clip before the to trans
women had to be on steroids for at least
two years or I think that's the case
before they start competing with it's a
year but they're taking female or female
hormones right whereas here we have a
girl on steroids literally a girl on
steroids
wrestling other girls so it's like no
matter which way you go with this thing
it's gonna be unfair we can't really
have equality when you're I guess doing
I'd be curious to see if there was
anybody trying to do it the other way
around and if not why not you know are
there any are there any males well I
like I might need to make sure I get
this right they are born female
but identify as a male and then go to
compete in male competitive sports you
know is that happening and if not why
not because you lose everything why
there's what does it call the Special
Olympics because if you put them to
compete against abled bodied people that
would be unfair but this is fair well
then that's a valid point because what
by the line of reasoning on I identify
as what prevents me from identifying as
a disabled person and entering the
Special Olympics you know where do you
draw the line where do you draw the line
whole question about all of this and who
is drawing it yeah so here's a scenario
just listen to her story
when I was a woman a man had a problem
with me when I was a trans guy trans and
queer people out a problem with me now
that I'm D transitioned Christians men
and a lot of radical feminists all have
a problem with me
[Music]
so this woman can't catch a break but
the show is called transitioned this
transgender person had a change of heart
mind later in life and D transitioned
but now she's being hated by the trans
community I guess because you're not
trans anymore and she just feels like
she totally doesn't fit in anywhere okay
wait a minute
isn't it isn't it a mental choice I mean
it's at least it starts with a mental
choice I believe I am this way so to say
that I no longer believe on that way why
would you hate somebody if you want the
freedom to believe you're a certain way
why would you be upset if somebody says
well you know I'm not that waning where
I believe on something different like
that doesn't make sense to me you can't
have it both ways yeah I think that's
the endgame of where this mindset will
lead you is it's okay to believe you or
anything
I mean you are somebody who came from
Mars I mean if you believe it you should
be it except for if you have a realistic
view back to the basics on where we
started this whole thing from then now I
know you're you're insane and you're
crazy and and that's a wrong mindset
their own ideology cannot coexist with
itself there's always gonna come up a
problem that makes it not equality
that's what they're wanting equality but
it's not equal so now Boy Scouts
organization inaugurates first all-girls
troop I think there's a word for that it
do they still convoy scouts or they just
call them Scouts now they're Girl Scouts
they're Boy Scouts of e-excuse me yeah
because there's Girl Scouts no to still
it's the first all-girl Boy Scout okay
the first said there's a word for this
why ninjas calm voice why not just call
them Girl Scouts on scout yeah your
scout because we're trying to push the
boundaries of confusion and this is the
world that Satan's all-girls troops Boy
Scouts
doesn't mean other further s what you
teach a girl is not what you teach a boy
right transitioned or not well welcome
to a spirited debate I'm Lauren Greene
Ontario Canada our neighbor to the north
has just passed a law giving the
government power to take children away
from their families if the parents do
not accept the child's chosen gender
identity it basically makes it a form of
child abuse this follows a 2012 law that
barred homeschooling families from
teaching their children that
homosexuality is a sin opponents fear
these laws have wide-ranging effects on
religious freedom here to discuss our
executive director of Catholics and
Alliance for the common good and
Christopher Hale and a senior pastor at
First Baptist Church and a Fox News
contributor dr. Robert Jeffress welcome
to you both thank you for having ank you
dr. Jeffers I want to get your reaction
to this first a lot a lot of strong
reaction on either side of this yeah
look this shows the hypocrisy of
liberalism you know liberals are the
ones who decry conservatives for not
believing in science and yet when it
comes to this issue of gender it is the
Liberals who are denying science
preacher brother that's what I'm saying
now you see we're supposed to have
freedom equality for all but you're not
allowed to teach your children and
almost sexuality is a sin you don't have
that freedom you're not allowed to tell
your child the parent child is not
allowed to tell the child that you
should think about this you know that
you're what you're wanting to do here in
other words influence only goes one way
but this is like this is like getting at
a core fundamental belief of what it
means to be free I believe that we live
in a free country a free society you
should be able to hey look if you want
to believe that you are a whatever a
trans person whatever I believe that you
have that freedom to be able to do that
right it's it's not something that that
I subscribe to or not something that I
would do but but hey that's part of
having a free society you are able to
believe that if you want to be a
Satanist you should be a Satanist
you-you-you should
have the freedom to be able to believe
like that I do not believe it's right
for a Christian to force his views on
someone else and all of a sudden make
laws and say listen we believe that
there's only two genders and if you have
a different idea of what a gender is
then I'm gonna try you if Flay you put
you in prison and all this kind of stuff
right I do not believe that is right at
all you should be able to have that
belief system is exactly what I disagree
with is where a trans person is going to
now write a public law that says you
cannot teach your child this viewpoint
and if you do we're gonna get you in
trouble for it that is a double standard
if I've ever seen a double standard and
that is not freedom that is forceful
totalitarianism that's right and and I
think it's a call to parents they need
to start having these conversations with
kids I mean that's why we wanted to do
this show in the first place like we've
got to start you know helping those
people that want to have a Christian
upbringing on an interview with you know
there's a there's a clear line between
what's right and what's wrong we have to
start having these conversations because
this is what's coming down the pipeline
and pretty soon you know it's just gonna
get worse and worse and worse and we
know that we're starting to see the
effects already people like comparing
Millennials to all the other generations
you know why are you guys waiting to get
married so long or not having kids well
why do you think look at what we're
dealing with nowadays you know it's
compared to previous generations he's
true when I was a kid this would this
was not even a thought yeah you know it
wasn't even heard of I'm sure there's
probably some terrible things that like
that have happened I mean all throughout
life you know if you ever seen the
documentary the Kinsley Report it's just
disturbing huge disturbing and and that
that was somebody who was writing the
sex laws back in the 1940s so this is
not a new topic so to say but but to the
fact that it's coming out in this way is
shocking to me
so I was doing some research on
sexuality in the media actually be
another segment of led live yeah yeah
absolutely
I think when you start covering more
topics like this because the generation
that we're trying to reach the the youth
this is what they're having to deal with
I mean these are real topics that need
to be discussed and those churches don't
want to touch it I can't wait to hear
people's comments on this please give us
your comments share this video we'd love
to hear what you got to say and keep
coming back subscribe hit the
notification bill and keep coming back
for more god bless you guys
[Music]